the most remarkable story is
that you almost didn't put maggie may
out maggie made the song maggie may
because you thought it was [ __ ] well now
the wreck the record company thought it
was [ __ ] oh
we had eight tracks for every picture
tells a story right and they said well
we need another track
have you got anything you know in the
cupboard or anything i said i've got one
more song i haven't finished it
yeah and that was maggie may and they
listened to it and said in their
infinite wisdom
this is not a great song but we'll put
it on anyway yeah well actually i didn't
think it was much good because it was
just so
rambling it didn't have a catch chorus
like he needed
isn't it amazing when you look back on
your career how many mistakes you could
have made like not putting out maggie
may would have been a major blunder well
i wouldn't have been sitting here today
howard yeah because what
you know you think about it like it's
just so
it's such a weird thing trying to
predict what people are going to like
musically oh it's awesome
it's almost impossible yeah and if you
reflect on it too much you could become
neurotic
i've never gone in the studio to try and
make a hit you know apart from do you
think i'm sexy i knew that was a hit but
otherwise
i go in the studio and make music that i
like right but if you get caught up in i
gotta make a hit i gotta make a hit
you'll never be a trendsetter because
you're going to try and repeat what you
did
yeah you disappear up your own bottom
really yeah but if you know what i mean
yes and you know when you think about
the odds of
like there's lots of one-hit wonders out
there but the idea of having a long-term
musical career i think that's why so
many artists turn to drugs
i'm talking about especially rock stars
because
you're not pointing the finger at me
you know how to party but you weren't
the most infamous party far from it lots
of people could bury you
you know like keith moon could could out
drink you and
bury me i'll tell you yeah you hung out
with him yeah and he tried to hang with
you for a whole night i mean you try to
hang with him for a whole night you
couldn't do it
24 hours it's absolutely impossible so
sad though
i've i've always been i've always been
very conscious of my body you know
because i've played
soccer all my life football as we call
it right i love to keep myself fit i've
never
really indulged that much in drugs you
even said in the days when
everyone was doing coke you wouldn't
snort it because you're afraid of your
voice i mean your voice is your money
maker your voice is your whole life
so you'd stick it in your ass right let
me uh
let me expand on that please ronnie was
having trouble with his nose
we've found a hole in the septum or
whatever it is so we had to find a new
method of
inhaling and so we used um
you know like cold pills and emptied
them out
and possibly suppositories like the
french do they stick everything up their
bum
and then you're sticking in your ass and
you still get high yeah
no kidding why don't more people do that
because they wreck their nose don't they
yeah you do you really do when you were
growing up because you have such an
unusual voice
yeah did people always tell you i'm
talking about when you were a kid
did they say to you like i imagine you
had dreams of being a singer
and would they say to you you don't you
you have such a raspy voice don't you
know you could never be a professional
singer
did people say that to you did they
knock you down no i don't sign that
because when i tried to sign for deca
records way back
in the early 60s and i talk about it or
i sing about it in the song you can't
stop me now
right well they were signing pretty boys
you know they didn't know what to do
with me had a big nose
load of hair funny clothes and i sung
with a rough voice they just couldn't
put me in a
category so therefore they didn't sign
me yeah and that's heartbreaking right
because you know you believe in yourself
and when
when a record company executive tells
you something you think they know
something
yeah of course you do and it can wreck
your spirit right yeah well it didn't
wreck mine because
my dear old dad said keep going keep
going your dad was a supportive guy
so much so much i always pictured you
from this rough
and tumble family you know soccer
players all that stuff
and that they would probably try to
discourage you and say that's no
business for
for a man you know you should be a
soccer player do something manly like
dig coal or something
i don't know well it was uh it was scary
in those days you know to go into the
music business and become
a singer right you know who knew it was
going to last 40 odd or 50 years like
it's lasted for me
when you went to school uh and you you
didn't grow up a wealthy man or anything
you could open up
from it were you the kind of kid
that got a lot of women i mean before
were you the kind of guy
everyone just sort of knew you were
going to be famous or you were going to
be somebody
or were you uh more of a guy who just
blended in with the wall
um i think i've always tried to stand
out somewhat but i didn't have much
success with the girls until i became a
singer was there ever a point you
decided i'm going to give all this up
because i i just can't make it was your
were there breaking points where you got
a lot of discouragement
um many times you know and you know
you know i had an apprenticeship of say
when i joined long john borges band when
i was 19
until maggie may which was when i was
26. when you joined
long john baldry's band yeah they
discovered you
singing on a train track somewhere yeah
how does that work you one of those guys
who sings like like in the subway here
in new york
yeah like an old drunk yeah is that what
you would do you would go down there
would you would you have a hat would you
ask for money
yeah well i was a i was a busker so
what happened we'd all been over to see
muddy waters or something like that
right
and uh john was on the same platform
going back to london as i was
i was laying on the floor playing
harmonica and he describes it
beautifully he said
i approached this pile of rags with a
nose sticking out
and this harmonica sound and it was rod
stewart and i asked him to join my band
and be a backup singer